her niece is with us in Atlanta
hi Trey nice how are you I'm fine how
are you good how can I help
already I'm 33 years old and a lot of
people in my family don't only own
homeless or for some reason I feel
inclined to die at home I don't think
that I'm not in position to get a home
I'm just trying to figure out if it's
the right decision right now because I'm
rinsing right now and I can have the
potential to save a lot of money to buy
a home or to be at home good place and I
don't have much it fit at all
I'm trying to figure out is that the
right decision to go in or do like do
you have to buy a home for most people
like you shake it home you should get it
homes I'm like yeah I should get a haul
there's no reason why I shouldn't well
the thing is this houses go up in value
so it is a good wealth building tool to
own a home plus owning a home you lock
in what you're paying per month for 15
years while you're paying it right and
after that you don't pay anything where
rent goes up every year your cost of
housing goes down if you own and you
also have the investment aspect that the
house goes up in value so home ownership
is a great goal you do not want to buy a
home until you get yourself in a good
financial position because owning a home
can be more expensive than renting and
it'll actually be a curse rather than a
blessing so I want you to actually
scares me that's what I want you to do
is clear up your debt real fast
be debt for having me you said you had
some debt I mean little with like big
hunger but okay pay it off good done hey
next one then is build an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses a
rainy day fund then save up your down
payment and once you've saved up a down
payment I don't you know that debt the
mortgage debts the only dead I don't
yell at people for other than that and
take out a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay with a good
strong downpayment and an emergency fund
left over and no debt at all other than
that and if you'll do that and then work
towards getting that house paid off
you'll put yourself in a real position
towards building wealth and turny says
we study millionaires and we have just
completed a massive study of
millionaires we find there are two or
three things that almost all the
millionaires do one is they get a nice
home and get it paid off quickly the two
is they systematically and consistently
invest in their 401ks and Roth IRAs in
good growth stock mutual funds those are
the two primary financial
characteristics financial moves that
that millionaires do and it's really not
fancy
it's just steady just steady just the
the tortoise rather than the hare and
that's the direction you go